it's a beautiful dignified classy night
of music and it's what the world needs
right
[Music]
from the Motown Records
[Applause]
we have to keep the secret formation you
know she's a mistress of ceremonies and
she was asking you know she wanted to
have a special moment and so we had to
keep it on the low especially because I
forever first lady was here so for
security purposes we had to you have to
keep it look it was beautiful it was
beautiful when Elisha was Alicia's
brainchild she wanted to show unity she
wanted to give good energy and great
vibes to the nya and it was a perfect
way to do it it was incredible I'm
having so much fun I feel so blessed I
feel grateful I've been a part of the
Grammy community for 10 years now and
just to be here to celebrate all these
beautiful artists is wonderful and I'm
just happy for everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey was it how was it Katie how much fun
was that
Katie pretty epic just sang with dolly
and all my friends I'm just on cloud
nine right now
I'm so happy for dolly she's got an
amazing week
[Music]
it's just so great it's all about the
audience they are so wonderful it's so
filled with love and it's pathetic there
were so much Grammy love for you out
there could you feel yes absolutely it
was so good
[Music]
so you're excited damn it
[Music]
Grammy award-winning artist Ariana
Grande
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's such an honor to be alongside so
many amazing women that I love and I
look up to and it's so cool to be on
this journey with them and to see so
many female artists in the new category
and hopefully we could see more and more
of that for many years to come because
it's really special
[Music]
what is this moment like right now I'm
really it's just unbelievable I mean
this record it's so personal to me it
means so much to me
and I played outside my own lines a
little bit and um you know I just I
wanted to make something that felt
really good and I wanted to take my time
and do it and I don't know I just feel
like I'm just thankful that I got the
chance to make the music